[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this evening we want to
tell you a story about collusion a real
one actual collusion that's currently in
progress there are no shadowy hackers or
imaginary rendevouz in prague in this
story there's not a single Russian spy
or secret sex tape there's nothing
shadowy about the collusion we're gonna
tell you about it takes place right out
in the open on live television this is a
story about where your news comes from
this past Sunday afternoon we learned
that the Trump campaign did not collude
with the government of Russia that was
the conclusion of Robert Muller's
investigation an investigation that
spent two years exhaustively looking
into the question this was very good
news for America we don't have a spy in
the White House but it was apocalyptic
for the Democratic Party and their press
agents in the news media these are the
people who had staked their reputations
and their fortunes on the collusion hoax
and they were stunned befuddled
politicians stammered on television
trying to figure out what to say about
the news viewers of liberal media
outlets didn't want to hear anything
about it huge numbers of them just quit
watching immediately last night CNN's
8:00 p.m. show lost nearly 50% of its
viewers for progressive channels this
was a catastrophe
something had to be done so into this
disaster step the Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi on Monday just hours after
the collusion story collapsed Pelosi
announced that the Democratic Party
would be switching gears going forward
Democrats would focus intently on health
care just like she disingenuously
claimed they always had atmosphere did
the Republicans help Democrats shift the
focus here from the investigation by the
health care
focus away I hope that it focuses the
press on these issues
I hope the press focuses on health care
Pelosi said she didn't have to ask twice
at Sina and they were paying close
attention to every word Pelosi uttered
to Jeff Zucker and the anchors who work
for him at CNN Pelosi isn't just a
politician
she's the leader of the party their
party the party under whose banner
sucker has said he may someday run for
office when America's most powerful
Democrat speaks CNN listens with pen in
hand these are marching orders and the
network's swung into action immediately
the run downs of every primetime show
were scrapped and rebuilt gone with the
segments about office towers in Moscow
and Carter pages spying and Don junior
going to prison in their place long
editorials about health care the
Democratic health care plan is sensible
and necessary CNN told us the Republican
plan cruel and heartless between 7:00
p.m. and midnight last night every show
on CNN followed Nancy Pelosi's
instructions every single show talked
about health care and every single one
Channel Nancy Pelosi views on health
care she could have been writing the
scripts maybe she was nobody hit that
topic harder than an anchor called Chris
Cuomo Cuomo was the son of the former
Democratic governor of New York and the
brother of the current Democratic
governor of New York he spends a lot of
time telling you what a committed shoe
letter journalist he is probably because
his instincts are so obviously political
last night the governor's brother read
his party's talking points as if off a
cue card close your eyes as we play this
and imagine you're listening to a
30-second attack ad on the radio during
campaign season see if you can tell the
difference our president said today that
the GOP will be known as the party of
health care but it seems to me he left
out a word based on his administration's
latest move with the ACA the president
will make his party about removing
health care this president and his party
have no plan to provide care to tens of
millions if the ACA is gone
why why welcome to the new normal
they're taking your health care away if
you're waiting to hear the paid for by
the Camelot Harris for president
committee line they left that out they
shouldn't have the law requires it but
they did anyway Don Lemon hosts the next
show in CNN's lineup as a person LeMond
isn't nearly as political as the
governor's brother is he's a local news
guy at heart the former weekend anchor
at a station in Birmingham he's not into
policy on the other hand Don LeMond has
a very sweet gig and he knows it
so when Jeff Zucker calls and tells him
to talk about health care he does and of
course he did the president says the GOP
is going to be the party of health care
then why is his Justice Department
saying the Affordable Care Act should be
struck down the president has said again
again
that he wanted to protect pre-existing
conditions it's just another yet another
lie from the president yet another lie
on health care at no point did any of
the anchors on CNN yesterday mention
what was so glaringly obvious in the
space of just 24 hours that channel went
from the Russia conspiracy Network to an
extended advertisement for the
Affordable Care Act as written by Barack
Obama the viewers those who remained
must have wondered what the hell was
going on where's my cigarette how Don
juniors going to prison I want to hear
more about that but no unplug these
orders it was health care week on CNN
and they were back at it this morning
assiduously starting at 6:00 a.m. today
every single show on CNN's morning
lineup and all through the day
regurgitating Pelosi's talking points to
the word about health care Republicans
will make you sick only Democrats will
make you well every single show made
that point if you were stuck in the
airport it was like living in North
Korea a speaker bolted to the wall above
your head blaring an endless loop of
propaganda you can't turn off giving
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
congressional Democrats just the opening
they needed and it puts health care for
millions of Americans in some level of
uncertainty and also jeopardy what would
happen I mean what would happen what
would millions of Americans lose just
just to be clear Republic
do not have a plan to replace Obamacare
the fate of health care for more than 20
million Americans insured through
Obamacare and Medicaid expansion hangs
in the balance
as of this moment Republicans have not
offered a single new alternative to
Obamacare
some people characterizing this as a
gift to Nancy Pelosi going into this
next twenty twenty election get rid of
Obamacare says the Trump administration
okay so what's the plan to replace it we
don't know says the Trump administration
simply repealing Obamacare without
Republicans coalescing behind an
alternative would throw the health care
system into chaos that is laughable you
read my mind I wanted to get your
respondent to the president saying that
we will have a plan laughable noted
laughable we have no idea what they've
been showing over on CNN for the past
four hours we had to turn it off at 4:00
p.m. but if we had to guess health care
oh I'm sorry
I'm getting worried I'm sorry we have a
news alert now according to our
producers who are monitoring the
situation both CNN and MSNBC are talking
about
that's right health care right now
health care close these orders what does
that tell you it tells you where your
news comes from Democratic officials
pick the topic and the story line their
servants and cable news dutifully repeat
it to the word all day long CNN is not a
news outlet it's a super PAC it is
running unregulated campaign ads 24
hours a day someone ought to call the
FEC about it